we begin this hour with a rare interview
with michael j fox the award-winning
actor is also an accomplished author
he's written four best-selling books the
latest no time like the future an
optimist considers mortality just came
out in paperback he's also the face of
the michael j fox foundation for
parkinson's research he has lived with
the disease for more than three decades
fox is married to actress chasey paulin
who he met on the set of the sitcom
family ties in the 1980s he shared this
very personal story about an emotional
moment with his wife
we were just married when i was
diagnosed
we've been married for 32 years i've
been diagnosed for 30 years so very
early in the marriage she got this
dumped on her
the moment that i told her
uh
was i i was realizing was the last time
we cried about it together
we haven't cried about parkinson since
we've just dealt with it and lived our
lives but we cried about it that first
time
and that and that was it and then we
just got it back to living with it do
you remember
that moment when you guys cried together
oh yeah absolutely well because she said
why i came from the doctors and i
obviously looked like i just got hit by
a truck and she said what happened i
said
i have parkinson's and we didn't know
what that meant
[Applause]
the year was 1991
and michael j fox was one of the biggest
names in show business
michael j fox family
but away from the success of celebrity
of hollywood beneath the surface
i feel four feet tall
fox was about to begin the biggest fight
of his life
we didn't know what to expect we didn't
know what would happen we didn't know no
no i could say when i would have more
effects more more symptoms than what i
had which was switching pinky they just
they just said it was coming hey you're
still here yeah i'm still here can you
believe it and i i realized i had a
drinking issue and i had to i was not
going to be able to deal with the
parkinson's until i dealt with that
i dealt with that that was like a night
fight in the closet that was like no fun
at all quitting drinking was very
difficult especially on the heels of
like i'm clearing away the the
stuff i put the alcohol i put on top of
things to hide it and that goes away and
then you're just left with that yeah
stuff with i am i'm a
married guy he had a two-year-old son i
got parkinson's and i got less than a
decade left to work
so it was it was pretty scary i had
hidden my symptoms and struggles very
well fox didn't reveal this parkinson's
diagnosis to the public for another
seven years it's a progressive brain
disorder that over time for many will
slowly strip away a person's movement
and speech i'd like to thank my my
doctors
dr cook who actually opened my brain
so you got to like a guy like that
and while scientists have made
significant strides with research and
treatment there is still no cure
unfortunately i have my operation in a
week's time and more than two decades
later and after a number of acting jobs
that allowed him to work without hiding
his condition
the sixty-year-old is now retired from
acting
he says he struggles with some of life's
basic day-to-day functions
and while fox is aware of the hurdles
that lie ahead
he's wise enough to understand what he
can control
and what he can't in the book you write
absent a chemical intervention
parkinson's will render me frozen
and you went on to say
it's a lesson in humility
how do you approach
every day
with this type of optimism it's hard i
mean i think about like last night i
went out for dinner i have a wheelchair
that i use every now and then it's it
still sucks
i have a hard time getting
uh to a restaurant and up the stairs to
to where my family is eating
perhaps at a dinner but then i'm there
with my
son and my three daughters and my wife
and
friends of ours and it's just like
that's great yeah what i love in here
you said
it's almost like you said i'm tired of
making lemonade out of lemons i'm out of
the lemonade business i don't have any
business it's it's so refreshing to hear
because
sometimes it's okay to admit that things
just suck right now completely unrelated
to persons had that tumor show up on my
spine yeah and it was on benign but but
it was imprinted on the spinal cord and
so they had to remove it and and um that
was really difficult and they left me
not being able to walk and i had to
learn how to walk again i had to go
through all this stuff i talked to my
family and letting me be alone for for
for a night in new york i wake up in the
morning by myself in new york and and i
get to get ready to get breakfast and
going to go to the shoot and i slept in
the kitchen i fell down and i shattered
my my humorous i thought i'm out of the
freaking lemonade business something i'm
out of it and then and and i thought who
am i to tell people cheer up and want to
tell people it's going to be okay i want
to tell people uh have a positive
attitude you know
you really got to go to that and check
that place and say is that just
something i say is that something i
believe
if it's something i believe is just
something i can live
and if i can live it is it is it
fair for me to ask others or subscribe
to others look at it the same way
um it's it's a heavy thing and i really
felt i felt that just felt so much
weight of of of of that public persona
being
mr optimus and i was still in mr optimus
and i knew in some small way i knew in
that moment
uh as dark as it was that i would get
back to that at some point the doc said
all his clients 25 minutes slow doc
i might understand you're still hanging
around with dr emmett brown mcfly
i read somewhere that last christmas
break you caught
back to the future and you admitted to
yourself
man i was damn good in that one
putting the lights on the tree and then
decoration on the tree and my my son was
there and two of my daughters and i went
in to get something in the other room
and and it was on tv zone and it was
back to the future it was right at the
beginning it was like i think the car in
the parking lot
and then after about 20 minutes they
realized i was gone i think about 20
minutes and half an hour i realized that
me and the dog had left
and then and they said what are you
doing i said
i'm watching back in the future
and i said what what what do you watch
about the picture i said
it's really good
are you telling me you built a time
machine
out of a delorean i'm great i'm really
good at this
i i never even realized that and
then all that crazy stuff was was
was was good it was just like what i was
doing to try to survive the moment
like my performance in that movie was
just like trying to
be alive because it was doing bus shows
at once hi
how you doing i'm big out from vegas
vinnie says hello
i know i was doing family ties in the
daytime and back feature at night
and then it was just a surreal
experience so that i had this moment now
who i am with all the stuff i had in my
life i just didn't look at that kid
and say he did all right he
had a lot to deal with and he was
dancing as fast as he could but he he
filled the wrong
did the job
wow oh wow he's very honest i see and i
appreciated that because we all go
through things and what he was saying is
it's okay to not be okay yes and you can
still find optimism even in your darkest
moments the last thing i said to him and
i wanted to make sure that he heard me
because i'm a huge fan
as an actor but also as a person
i said
your public fight
has given millions private strength
that's true and
i don't think he hears that often enough
yeah because he has been living out loud
in front of the world for so long but it
is true you know and you don't think
about the pressure that must feel
sometimes that's why i like him saying
you know i'm tired of making lemonade
yeah and it's okay to admit you know
what this does suck yeah this does suck
this doesn't feel good but boy when you
look at his life when you look at family
ties i love that show loved a minute
back to the future he can say i was damn
good and that gives you pride in that
yeah it's so unusual too nate for people
to say you know i was good in that i
like that he said that yeah i'm glad he
can appreciate himself it's true i
really i it's also remarkable and a
reminder that he has parkinson's and
people are aware of that they think of
him and that but it doesn't mean all
your other problems in life go away
right so dealing with all these other
issues right that people deal with and
so the the courage required to go down
the list is remarkable you're spot on he
said i still have to be a husband and a
father and a friend and a friend he's
also running the foundation which has
raised over a billion dollars for parks
and research or helped raise um but his
book though right now no time like the
future an optimist considers mortality
is on sale now